my name is Bob Thomas I'm the CEO of for
equities we own Sunset Golf Village we
own Pond Ridge Estates the Galleria at
the Glen and several other buildings
that don't have names there by train
stations during this challenging time we
hope you're getting some well-deserved
rest and relaxation and using this time
to reconnect with your family you
deserve it we wanted to clear up some
misconceptions first and foremost rent
will be due on the first of every month
as it has been since the time our Lord
Jesus Christ walked the earth and will
be until he returns to us we understand
that many families are making sacrifices
right now you might be choosing between
eating and keeping the roof over your
head and to this we say maybe it's time
to lose a little weight
tighten the belt and make those tough
choices we're making tough choices here
too we've closed down all of our gyms
and common areas and just last week we
had to put my wife kitty into a
pre-emptive coma because she was being
hysterical
we will be complying with a state law
that mandates that there be no evictions
in 90 days but on the 91st day we will
be marshalling the full resources of our
considerable legal team and focusing
them solely on you we will literally go
to the ends of the earth to make it
right
here at Thor equities you and your
family's health and safety is paramount
to us which is why we'll be going
through all of the tenants in our
building and identifying people that
work in high-risk professions and then
removing them I bought my first building
when I was 15 years old and there were
no pandemics back then you had to get
tenants out the hard way by terrorizing
them until they killed themselves at
Thor equities many of our subsidiary
companies have been asked to produce
ventilators and we've declined that
request because we don't want to take
away someone's incentive to breathe my
brother worked at Cantor Fitzgerald and
we lost him in 9/11 and as he was laying
there in the rubble he was still trading
that's what this country is about and
that's what you're about and that's what
for equities is about so keep fighting
because we're not gonna make it easy for
you we believe in you too much